by the way did you see jinsaki crying
yeah on that podcast yeah i did she was
did you see that or no dude she wasn't
she crying she was crying because of the
go ahead
she was crying uh because of the
desantis the law being put into the
thing where that you can't teach she's
thinking it's the most messed up thing
that you can't teach she's again she's
saying that it's it's anti you know
anti-gay she says how can you do this to
kids who are going through this and if
they want to be trans you have to let
them be in and then she starts crying
says you don't know how much this hurts
me and i'm like i'm like i'm watching
i'm like wait what my buddy tim dillon
had the best take on that i can't
remember the exact tweet but it was
basically like uh it wanted that he
quote tweeted one of these teachers that
was like how am i
not supposed to talk to if i have a if i
tell my students that i had a wonderful
weekend with my gay lover like how why
would i not be allowed to do that um and
tim dillon goes you know that's cool and
all but
my the everyone knows that all the best
teachers are like this mysterio these
mysterious figures you didn't know
anything about him they came in with a
ratty jacket and ratty hair and
taught you actually learned [ __ ] they
never talked about their personal lives
you didn't know what kari drove you
didn't know he lived yeah and you didn't
know his first name right now
mrs williams she's in she's out but
yeah and then what was the what was the
kicker to that that's it it was just
that you know sometimes his takes are
more brilliant than they are you know
hysterical but that was it it's like it
really got me to thinking like yeah what
are we talking about here why would you
need to know your the personal lives of
your teacher
on any level not to mention i mean it's
just ridiculous i don't know about you
guys patrick i the only time i learned
about sex as a child and i remember the
room i forgot how young i was it was
just a slideshow quick of the male body
parts the female body parts it was
awkward everybody was kind of you know
giggling that was it bro it was up to
our parents but you know middle eastern
parents there's no birds and bees it's
just like you better figure it out on
your own but it was one day in class why
why the anger it bothers me is the anger
of why can't we teach them what we want
it's like bro relax let the parents
teach their kids about sex and and honey
there's you know think about dude
kindergarten you know how confusing it
is just to be a kindergarten like
they're they're
kids trying to feel like you're a boy
but you could be a girl but you could
change it on thursday it's too much
information for a child bro wait wait
down the road they're gonna trust me
they're gonna see it if they're watching
netflix i'm expecting they're gonna see
it when they get older you know what i
mean yeah the kids used to figure it out
on their own when they when you saw the
picture of the male genitalia either you
felt something in your belly or you
didn't because or when you saw the
female
genitalia you're like oh something about
that i like
exactly you didn't yeah there was no
they weren't like here's what to do with
this yeah exactly okay let me let me and
you could get rid of yours i'm going to
throw you guys a completely different
angle here with that i actually really
enjoy
that these people are trying to force
these beliefs down people's throat
because what's happening right now i'm
not saying whether you're on the left or
on the right is that at the end of the
day common sense is prevailing of course
and at the end of the day people are
like i don't know about this bro like i
don't
why is it like any i don't care what
side you're on anytime you just like
what what's going on like that look
whatever
that thing
it's not adding up it's not making sense
and i and and and whether you
were on the on the left and you didn't
see what you saw what trump was doing
you're like i don't know about this or
you're on the right and you're just a
common sense person and you're seeing
this don't say gay stuff and this disney
stuff and you're just like
you're it's a losing proposition at the
end of the day
common sense is what people yearn for
yeah and great what they gravitate to
and if you're on the side of like
pandering to your point tony of to like
a small segment of society you're gonna
[ __ ] lose yeah right but it's it's
just it just boggles my mind how and i'm
not i'm not right on my left i'm just in
the middle how this side this presidency
this administration they had
talked all that trash trump's gone right
they had all this time to at least pick
somebody they went with joe biden
whatever he's a familiar face 81 million
votes i still can't believe it you had
all this time to make a stand and change
and really make a difference what have
what have they done and i hate when
people just say infrastructure i don't i
don't care about infrastructure
everything is going wrong nothing is
going right you had all this time you
talked all this [ __ ] about trump what
are you guys doing and nothing and
they're just with [ __ ] like this like
the the white house gensake is furious
and crying because it's not cool not to
teach these kids about sex in general
but they're gonna pay the price for this
i mean there's you're seeing i mean
you're gonna see it let me tell you let
me tell you what's gonna happen let me
tell you okay
this is so ridiculous how idiotic they
are when it comes down to strategy
there's two different ways what's the
saying would you rather win the battle
or the war the war okay these guys are
all winning battles let me explain
the more they do this okay the more they
play this game and pushing whatever down
kid's throat
every pastor and church right now
is going to be using that message and
grow attendance
you're right because here's how pastors
going to use it they're going to say
how many of you are sending your kids to
public school if you're sending your
kids to public school and you're worried
about the values and the principles
there's never been a more important time
to plug your kids into a church
because the school's not going to do it
so their stupid ideas and philosophies
is going to help the organization they
least want to exactly and number two all
this [ __ ] they're feeding a parent
who's sitting there who was okay doing
what they were doing now they're saying
no
my kids are gonna go to a christian
private school or private school that's
catholic or private school that's
whatever that's teaching strong
values and principles i'll bust my ass
to make that additional thousand dollars
to send them to private school private
schools are going to go up public school
are going to get their assets handed to
them homeschooling's going to go up
they don't realize how strategy and you
know war works
it doesn't work the way they're doing it
they're idiots i'm telling you i believe
that they're ideas i'm seeing it short
term they will win
look what the santa's how do you think
disney's board is sitting right now
sitting saying guys 50 since 19 so for
55 years we've not paid any taxes the
hell did you guys just do it we went
woke by the way do you know how much
money that is that's insane do you know
how much money that is oh my god you're
not talking about like a couple million
you're talking real money billions
that's called stupid that's what it's
called dumb stupid yeah you made certain
things you said that is stupid and you
had freedom and now you don't yeah now
you're paying a price for it but what
they said the other day like they're not
going to stop calling kids boys and
girls dude they're going to only call
kids dreamers and fairy bells or
whatever the hell that is
boys and girls
and i i think tony i want to know you
guys honest opinion i think personally
that that whole
she he the them that started because the
generation i think one or two after me
hitting your kids became taboo because
you know this if i went to my father and
he's like vinnie come here and i was
like excuse me dad as a middle eastern
father and i went it's he them they or
whatever he would be like they are
moving the [ __ ] out of this house today
like it's i'm not saying meeting your
kids but that generation where you can't
even talk
or be like listen relax chill like
because now it's it's just free falling
i saw somebody
they sh it was the on on certain days it
was the them she and i'm like if you
think i'm gonna [ __ ] take the time to
be like what's today and what are you i
i can't bro that's why i'm moving out of
california i i have i have two emotions
right now a ton of excitement and
confidence and a ton of fear which
combine it together produces urgency
yeah is what it produces beautiful and
i'm good with that yeah i want whatever
that produces if you enjoyed this short
clip click over here to watch another
short clip and if you want to watch the
entire episode the entire podcast click
here
[Music]